[Music]
thank heaven it is time now for final
exam our fact heavy after-dinner mints
and you have earned it this week we of
course hit hard news professionals
against one another to determine who's
been paying closest attention to the
news this week our defending champion is
of course Katie Pavlich of town hall she
has killed opponent after opponent this
week her challenger guy Benson host of
Benson and harp a very good competitor
himself you can hear him on fox news
radio every day you both know the rules
but I'm gonna repeat them for our
audience might be tuning in for the
first time in a while hands on buzzers I
ask the questions the first one to buzz
didn't gets to answer the question you
have to wait until I finish asking it in
order to answer you can answer once I
acknowledge you by saying your name each
correct answer with one point each
incorrect answer two tracks a point from
your total best of five wins are you
ready Friday they are I know you are a
little nervous that's okay you should be
nervous
question one a man in New York City set
a dangerous world record recently for
speed slicing of a type of fruit he did
it on his stomach using a machete he
chopped his way through 26 of these in
just one minute
what kind of fruit was he slicing guy
Benson watermelon oh you're so you're
decisive on that I think you may know
the answer let's see if you do to the
tape Oh is he doing I think you use
cutting a watermelon set Maury Povich
right looks like this really the truth I
think I mean first my first reaction is
I'm relieved that I didn't kill myself
and the second thing is that I'm
exhilarated okay wow you are an esoteric
sports fan you just knew that you
weren't even guessing question - I don't
think was my PO just clarify that was
not Maury Povich well you are not the
father this is a multiple-choice
question here it is online shopping has
of course caused many brick-and-mortar
stores to close as of this week which
popular business from the 80s and 90s
has exactly one store left in the u.s.
is it a Tower Records is it B
Blockbuster Video is at C Circuit City
I'm not going to risk to losing a point
here I don't know Katie Pavlich
blockbuster is it you're just guessing
mm-hmm will she be rewarded for rolling
the dice to the tape Alaska is final
just her video store rent out their last
movies and close up shop the two
closures in Anchorage and Fairbanks will
leave the blockbuster in Bend Oregon as
the last store standing fortune favors
the bold knowing that you could have
wound up with a negative one you did it
anyway
paper reza regain the position of parody
a tie with guy benson question three it
will not be a tie when this is done a
bloomberg index that calculates the net
worth of billionaires says there is a
new richest man in the world in world
history actually he's worth 150 billion
he's also the 25th largest landowner in
this country who is it kitty peplum jeff
bezos another decisive answer is it in
fact Jeff Bezos Jeff Bezos is now the
richest man in modern history his net
worth topped 150 billion
I suspect that mr. Bezos can live on the
interest on the interest on the interest
on the interest from his one hundred and
fifty billion dollars but I digress it's
funny given what he pays his employees
you'd never know he was rich washington
post's not a generous man okay good
answer though to the one candy pad which
question for the guy this is your chance
the rain came down hard in Washington on
Tuesday and something a little spooky
took place at the White House at the
very moment Trump was speaking to
reporters about his Helsinki trip what
happened
Katie the lights went out the lights
went out
is that true to the tape intelligence
agencies I have a full faith in our
intelligence agencies
[Music]
okay
another helping of deep state anyone
suspicious anyone suspicious the Capitol
dome got struck by lightning - that was
kind of amazed did it really yeah thanks
do you bet that we just paid to get that
fixed today so it's three to two so
conceivably we could wind up with a tie
I think it's three two one three two one
Rob okay well I don't know I'm not good
at math we're gonna move into the final
question here House Speaker Paul Ryan
says he has not been able to drive
lately because some animals eat his
truck what type of animals ate his truck
Cady woodchucks woodchucks seriously yes
seriously - the tape so I towed it into
the dealer they put it up and they they
realize that a family of woodchucks
lived in one their body of like my
suburban they ate all the ring out of it
my car was eaten by animals how would
she know that well I know that's because
I listened to that but I also growing up
we took the car to the dealership and
there was a squirrel in the engine but
not a would show out of which I mute but
situation but guess what Chuck but I
knew that answer huh one of the more
esoteric of our suburban forest animals
yes they're not raccoons amazing Katie
felt your unstoppable force guy you got
one offer which is better than I could
have done to be fair the only reason I
have this gig is because of guy
apparently so that was amazing alright I
don't know how many of our Eric whemple
surprise face mugs you have we're giving
you another for a full dinner so I'm
gonna run CH with all these mugs so you
sure yeah right there we should he's a
great thank you both die Benson fainted